have you looked up your Uber rating I  just did and I'm a little upset uh  because I'm I think I'm very nice to my  Uber drivers Beyond nice at one point I  even offered a drive  I'm the best person to do I don't want  music I don't want anything on complain  I don't do anything I got a 4.88  i i rate them five stars no matter what  every time what am I gonna do I'm going  to ruin somebody's life or drive me in a  car I go F5 I don't care five I don't  know if I'll ever see you again well  five five five I don't know if I could  get rate people Everyone start rating  people this is gonna be a disaster of a  society where it's like hi I'm a 3.5  yeah I figured I figured well it turns  out you have a higher rating than I do  oh this is unbelievable but we've been  in Ubers together many times and we will  be in many more